yes before Kratos was a badass hell bent
on the destruction of the God of War he
was a badass who wanted to be hell bent
on the destruction of the God of War
which still pretty badass God of War
ascension so God of War ascension is
another god of war game for the
PlayStation 3 and it takes place before
God of War 1 the story of God of War
ascension is Kratos wants to break his
bond with Ares but you can't just do
that I guess we were told you could in
the previous games but well I guess the
fact is you cannot because we need
another god of war game so for Kratos to
break his bond and break his oath with
the God of War Ares so he can kill him
yes it take on the three sisters the
Furies and go through a myriad of other
puzzles and realms and levels and get
new trinkets and it's a god of war game
you know it by now now if you're a fan
of the God of War games you're gonna be
right at home with God of War ascension
it's fun is it perfect no but it's a lot
of fun you're going through you got your
blades of chaos your slashing through
guys the thing I didn't like about the
combat in this game is in the previous
God of War games you spend your red orbs
you get new abilities you get new
attacks new combos and you go forth
unleash those on the demonic in
this game you buy the new combos with
orbs yeah you gotta build up your rage
meter then you can use those combos the
rage meter is this meter where you build
it up by hitting guys and not getting
hit yourself
so really you got a string together a
bunch of combos your rage meter goes up
to the point where odd now it's filled
up now you can unleash the Beast you
know that one do you know the hit hit
hit hit hit goes back it's all slum on
and boom got a war standard right there
yeah those moves however if you get hit
by enemies that meter will drop so now
it's not full anymore so you got to
build it back up some of these enemies
though they hit you hard and that meter
just goes away you're like great now I
got to start over which does result in a
number of these combat situations that
you get into being like hit hit dodged
hit hit dodged hit hit dodged sweet rage
meters up by the Vavoom oh I got hit hit
hit dodged hit hit dodged got it takes
away from the fun of Ghana for the other
god of war games knew what it was it
knew what you wanted and it gave it to
you you bought combos and abilities with
orbs go crazy here they are they're all
yours right now I get in terms of the
story Kratos is not as enraged as he is
in the other god of war games you have
to get human rage so they illustrate
that with this rage meter but it does
feel like you're playing a nerf bat
version of God of War combat and they
want to make it more challenging for you
to pull off being full-fledged Kratos
because when you
the doctor like I earned that a lot of
the combat and God of War ascension does
feel like nerf down Ghana for combat the
game is still fun and everything is just
big the cinematography is great you hook
onto things you flip around there's a
lot of those annoying parts where it's
like you push square now oh you didn't
you died but I didn't know I had to push
square damn it lot of that in this game
but when you do pull those off you also
do feel like a badass the camera follows
Kratos down he's slicing on the big huge
things he's swinging around their heads
and he's taking their claws and ramming
him into their faces and you do get new
items there's just one item it's the
coolest item in the game you can healer
DK items it's meant for puzzles you
can't just do it to anything you
activate this amulet you're like Oh heal
it and the bridge comes back or you can
decay it it's really cool but the game
is still linear it's not like you're
creating alternate paths and it does
make you question the game there will be
times words like oh that statue just
broke apart I can't go that way
it's like we have an amulet you could
you can just heal the statue and then go
into the cave but you can't because the
game doesn't want you to go into the
cave but want you to go around which
turns me into a five-year-old because I
just keep going but why a little bit of
inconsistency with this item but the
item was cool and when the gameplay
wants to be controlled or breaking tough
its controller breaking tough this one's
seen everyone who's played this game
knows this scene you're going up in this
elevator and you are just fighting dudes
but does not just dudes it's like three
Medusa's who all whip you with their
tails and these electrical witch
were shooting electricity at you hit hit
dodge hit hit dodge ooh the Medusa's
going to swing at you with her tail
dodged that the other ones going to
swing dodge that the other ones going to
swing dodge that right now the first
ones cooldown is done so now it's going
to swing with this tail at a point
you're like this is a complete dodge
fest and that's case in point if I were
just able to be badass kratos like the
other god of war games i could just tear
into these people but i can't
because the game won't let me I hated
that elevator though I hated it the
multiplayer is pretty fun to multi
players in everything these days
multiplayer isn't a new thing but it's
very marketable
everyone wants multiplayer in their game
so God of War now has multiplayer it's
pretty standard multiplayer modes you
know you got capture the flag your
all-out team-based battles you know
you've seen all the modes before what I
really liked about it though is you
choose which god you worship and that
gives your guys special abilities I
thought that was really cool you can
customize the armor and you can't deny
the multiplayer is fun there's something
about someone attacking you and kicking
the out of you and to your guys
come to your aid and then you start
kicking the piss out of that guy and
then
you joined in the fight you guys just
tear the out of that guy you're
like we're Spartans more than that we're
bros and like I said before there is a
big part of me that feels like they're
adding Lord of God of War for the sake
of adding lore for the sake of making a
new game you know God of War one it's
like after Kray ptosis family was killed
he knew Ares was his true enemy there
was actually a lot of stuff that
happened in between that called gotta
for ascension but I'm going to forget to
mention it right here really strange
isn't it but the game does fit into
Loren if it doesn't perfectly fit into
lore it's at least fun enough for you to
be like yeah let it fit into Loren after
that it's all subjective as to whether
or not you feel like a 9-hour
single-player campaign is worth dumping
60 bucks on but I will say that God of
War ascension is worth buying at full
price it's not as good as God of War 3
but it is more of what I love about god
of war and it is a good addition to the
series so if you played God of War
ascension what did you think and what is
your favorite god of war game whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you